health officials are making an ongoing
effort to try and get more nebadon's
vaccinated and part of that effort is
cold hard cash
today nevada starts its vax nevada days
raffle
bianca holman is live this morning with
a look at what is coming up later today
jackie good morning hey good morning
john we're here at the csn north las
vegas campus and so
this is where it's all going to happen
governor steve sisolak is going to be
here to draw the first winners
in the vax nevada days campaign so
here's more about it if you haven't
heard about it
so this is a push to get more nevadans
vaccinated against the coronavirus
everyone is entered into the statewide
rafter raffle
after they get their first shot there's
a total of five million dollars in cash
prizes all from federal money
so tonight they'll draw names for big
cash prizes ranging from one thousand
dollars to 250 thousand dollars
there's also tuition credits for
students fishing licenses and state park
passes
the drawings will continue for eight
weeks culminating with one lucky person
winning a million bucks
next month it's certainly an incentive
to get people to
to get their vaccination if they haven't
gotten it yet and those that all got
their vaccine will also be entered
so that gives them the fairness of the
you know because they got it when they
were available to them
so people have been very positive about
it
so like the governor said whether you
got your vaccine in january or yesterday
you'll be entered and you can still
get vaccinated to get into the drawing
over the next eight weeks
so that's some good news there so again
when it comes to next week and they're
drawing
if you get it the vaccine tomorrow you
could be up to win next week and so
again it all goes down today
here at the north las vegas csn campus
at 6 pm we'll definitely bring you all
the action back to you guys in the
studio
thank you very much and as bianca did
mention the first winners of the state's
vax nevada days program will be
announced at six o'clock this evening
and we're going to announce the winners
during our newscasts coming up
at six so make sure you check in with
eight news now this evening